[Music]
on this sunday night ominous appointment
russia's new man in charge of the
invasion of ukraine he has a reputation
for
unrelenting brutality chilling signals
of the showdown to come
also tonight cruising makes a comeback
canada welcomes its first ship since
kovid grounded the industry
plus passports delayed the passport
office is pretty much getting your
passport
a day before you leave a surge in demand
driving a backlog and putting travelers
on ed
and when news gets personal i literally
feel like i'm paying a piece of my soul
every time i tell a story the
award-winning journalist covering
stories that hit close to home
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
sophie louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
the threat to kiev is receding but fear
is rising in eastern ukraine as russia
builds up its forces in the region
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says the country is bracing itself for a
hard battle that experts warn could
start in a matter of days there are
ominous signs russian attacks in many
parts of ukraine are escalating and the
kremlin has appointed a new commander to
lead the invasion ross lord has our top
story tonight
with russian attacks in eastern ukraine
escalating streams of mostly women and
children continue their desperate
journey to safety over the polish border
some barely survived the shelling at the
crumotorsk train station that killed
dozens
as they stagger through their living
nightmare russia's barbaric attacks will
be directed by a new general alexander
devornikov notorious for ordering
atrocities in chechnya and syria it
seems this is one of the last
best hopes that vladimir putin has
and we should not underestimate the
resources that are still
at the disposal of the russian military
ukraine's ambassador to the united
kingdom says the new russian offensive
is likely aimed at having something for
vladimir putin to boast about in time
for may 9th an anniversary known in
russia as victory day what we're
constantly reminding our people that we
should do anything to but just just
never turn into animals the russians
russians already are
as machines work to clean up after the
slaughter of civilians in the city of
bucha there are more ominous signs like
this russian convoy estimated at 13
kilometers long in eastern ukraine's
harkee region in his continual pursuit
of more support from nato countries
ukrainian president volody mirzalenski
claims russia is targeting not only his
country but all of europe never have
said
ukraine even civilians returning to kiev
after russian soldiers retreated are not
sure where they stand i came to
to
pick up a few myself and go
away again
because we have some
proper situation with russian
troops i think and we don't know still
it's safe to be here or not as calls
intensify for european countries to end
all purchases of russian oil and gas
there's another effort at diplomacy this
one by austrian chancellor carl nehamer
he's met with zolensky and meets next
with putin niehamer says he wants to
build bridges and stop what he calls the
war of aggression as the world watches
and wonders what it will take to make it
stop
ross lord global news well many around
the world have condemned the ruthless
attacks on ukrainian civilians calling
them war crimes a warning our coverage
includes some disturbing images tonight
the u.s says the wheels are in motion to
build a case against russian president
vladimir putin as jennifer johnson
reports top prosecutors from the
international criminal court are
pursuing thousands of cases
the brutal attacks against ukrainian
citizens have horrified the world
the biden administration says it is
working with its allies to put russian
president vladimir putin on trial
ukraine has set up an online archive to
document the atrocities these are war
crimes these are shocking and brutal
acts that are completely unacceptable
and the united states will work with the
international community to make sure
there's accountability cell phones are
recording the brutality that has gone
beyond the usual boundaries of war
attacks on civilian targets allegations
of rape torture and extreme deprivation
all can constitute war crimes or crimes
against humanity captured russian
soldiers are reportedly saying they were
told to bomb civilian areas even handing
over maps we filed uh all the criminal
charges in the international court we
have the criminal cases opened in
ukraine more than four thousand of
individual criminal cases already by the
prosecutor general we have ten more
countries that open their own
individual criminal prosecutions and
we're providing all the evidence to them
along with putin ukraine officials are
vowing to prosecute soldiers and
military commanders both on the ground
and in russia international war crimes
investigators are in ukraine risking
their own lives to defend those whose
lives were savagely taken
experts warn evidence gathering is a
slow task people should be prepared for
some time and the complexity of the
process that this is not going to be
immediate and this is not going to be
easy
no sitting head of state has ever been
tried for war crimes finding and
arresting a heavily protected vladimir
putin won't be easy but in-person
prosecution is required by international
law
vladimir putin needs to be charged and
go to justice
or die with an indictment hanging over
his head
russia has repeatedly denied it has
committed any war crimes but the
evidence has been overwhelming and
broadcast all over the world
images that have haunted millions and
galvanized leaders from the u.s canada
and their allies to make putin pay
jennifer johnson global news washington
french president emmanuel macron is set
to face far-right candidate marine le
pen in a runoff following the first
round of france's presidential election
macron is projected to win round one
with around 28 percent of the vote but
le pen is not far behind at 23 percent
the two front runners set to face each
other again april 24th when voters will
decide if macron will stay in power for
five more years macron was the runaway
favorite for most of the campaign thanks
in part to his active diplomacy with
ukraine and france's strong economic
recovery but le pen who's running on an
anti-immigration platform made
significant gains in the last few days
after shifting her focus to cost of
living issues
now to the pandemic shanghai's 26
million residents are still under a
harsh lockdown prompted by a surge in
infections but the zero covered strategy
has spurred a barrage of complaints
about food shortages on chinese social
media many stuck in their homes say food
and other essential goods are running
out with supermarkets shut down and
delivery services strained the city has
been delivering some supplies to homes
and says it is trying to secure more
goods the lockdown had been scheduled to
end last week but it has been extended
indefinitely
after a two-year lockdown in the cruise
industry the first ship has sailed back
into canadian waters this weekend cruise
ships saw some of the most dire
outbreaks early on in the pandemic
resulting in crushing measures to the
sector there are high hopes now as the
season officially begins but as
katherine erkart reports kovig could
complicate the comeback
it was a welcome sight for the
beleaguered canadian cruise industry
holland america's conning stamp cruised
under the lions gate bridge and into the
port of vancouver early sunday the first
cruise ship to arrive in canada's
largest port since the pandemic started
more than two years ago it's vitally
important and i just want to acknowledge
how hard everyone has worked to make
today possible
about 1200 passengers and 900 crew were
on board in total 310 cruise ships are
expected to arrive in vancouver in 2022
with cruise ships making their way to
vancouver and other ports across canada
this season is
an exciting time for our travel and
tourism sectors in halifax the industry
resumes april 26 with a total of 152
vessels due to dock in the port of
halifax this year nationwide cruising
generates billions of dollars and
provides thousands of jobs cruising in
canada is an important part of our
tourism economy and prior to the
pandemic accounted for
30 000 jobs and contributed more than 4
billion to
the canadian economy annually
canada lifted its pandemic-related ban
on cruise ships november 1st with
conditions
everyone on board must be fully
vaccinated and passengers must test
negative before boarding
the conning stamp had no confirmed covet
cases before arriving in canada we've
been working closely with transport
canada and other global health experts
as well as officials from this city and
port to make sure we're able to deliver
the cruise experience our guests are
looking forward to and one that is safe
early in the pandemic at least 40 cruise
ships suffered outbreaks before the
industry ground to a halt among the
worst the diamond princess more than 700
of the 3 700 passengers and crew on
board became infected while quarantined
in yokohama japan
14 deaths were connected to the outbreak
return of the cruise industry in canada
comes as some experts warn of a sixth
wave of the pandemic
clearly many passengers believe their
love of cruising outweighs any risks
catherine erkart global news vancouver
well by water land or air many canadians
are itching to travel now that
restrictions have eased and that means
dusting off the old passport turns out
after leaving them in a drawer for more
than two years many travelers are
discovering their passports have expired
as sarah reed reports that's leading to
nerve wracking delays for those in a
rush to renew
when going to service canada everyone
expects to wait sometimes it's a couple
of hours but you can sit there and plan
your morning to do that that's the way
it used to be this is what people face
now long lines just to make an
application and then long waits for a
passport to arrive
it says online
20
business days plus or minus
and so that would actually take us a
little bit into the beginning of may so
i'm hoping it's on the minus side that's
because taylor heiselmeier is planning
to travel to the u.s next month with so
many people trying to renew their
documents the wait time is actually on
the plus side with most people receiving
their new passports months after
applying
so we're also seeing people that have
already mailed their passports in to get
renewed paid the renewal fee
head over head over to canada place and
actually do another appointment and pay
another fee and pay an express fee just
to get their passports in time
according to service canada the delays
are being caused by increased demand
from april 2020 to march 2021 it issued
363 000 passports but from april of last
year to march this year that number
jumped to 1.2 million trying to plan
ahead and get things done and and you
know we're busy and and so it's
uh
a little bit disheartening and just
really frustrating and difficult so
while vacations are supposed to be
relaxing
if you have a trip booked and it's
within the two weeks the passport office
is pretty much getting your passport
a day before you leave
meaning your dream vacation quickly can
become a travel nightmare
sarah reed global news
loblaw and pepsico have resolved a
pricing dispute that kept several
popular snacks off store shelves for
more than a month the canadian grocery
giant confirming with global news both
sides have reached an agreement with
products starting to be shipped out
tomorrow frito-lay products such as
cheetos doritos lays and ruffles were
kept out of loblaw's store since late
february the company expects stores to
be fully stocked before easter weekend
coming up the thin blue line calgary
police at an impasse over a
controversial patch
and later the miniature library that'll
have you reaching for a magnifying glass
a disturbing discovery in spain police
have seized one of europe's largest
collections of taxidermy animals from
elephants to polar bears more than one
thousand stuffed specimens were found
inside two warehouses among them
endangered species like the bengal tiger
along with some now extinct animals the
collection's owner is now being
investigated for potential smuggling
a controversial patch is pitching
calgary police against its citizens
oversight committee last week the
calgary police commission ordered
officers to stop wearing thin blue line
patches but so far many members are
refusing to comply heather urix west
explains why
it's a symbol stoking division in
calgary it's concerning that calgary
police officers consider it acceptable
to ignore a lawful direction they
personally disagree with on march 30
calgary's police commission directed the
service to remove the thin blue line
patches from all police uniforms citing
the symbol's mixed meaning for some it's
a way of acknowledging police and
honoring fallen officers but thin blue
line imagery has also come to be
associated with racism and white
supremacy after prominent displays of
the symbol at black lives matter counter
protests we made it very clear
that to racialize communities black and
indigenous calgarians the symbol is
directly offensive and an exact
contradiction to the idea that black
people's lives have value calgary is far
from the first jurisdiction to ban
officers from wearing the patch edmonton
ottawa toronto and nationally the rcmp
have all done the same but with the
support of their union many calgary
police officers are refusing to comply
removing patches from the uniforms is
one thing
but completely vilifying the symbol and
its meaning to our people
which has been which has been
communicated
is very much another calgary's police
chief says the directive will be
enforced but not for two weeks adding
that the issue eliminates a growing
distrust between officers and members of
the police commission our members are
paying very close attention to the
social media accounts of
of individual counselors
and the quantity of anti-police
content that's being sort of posted
shared or liked is is really causing
concern to the members there's gonna
have to be uh serious discussion perhaps
the sheer number of officers who are
defying this it's going to be incredibly
challenging the calgary police
commission is standing by its directive
maintaining that sooner or later all
police service members will have to
comply heather eurix west global news
calgary
ahead on global national beyond the
headlines journalism with a very
personal connection
[Applause]
another first since the pandemic began
worshipers from around the world
traveling to jerusalem for palm sunday
parishioners lined the streets for a
procession before prayers echoed in the
church during mass palm sunday marks the
start of the holy week for christians
well the recent meetings in rome between
pope francis and indigenous delegations
from canada attracted dozens of
journalists to report on the historic
event but for one correspondent from the
aboriginal people's television network
covering the visit hit very close to
home nitu garcia reports
do you feel you were speaking on behalf
of the 250 little voices that can no
longer speak for themselves aptn
journalist tina house interviewing to
come loops to sweat mccook p roseanne
kasmir in rome this represents the
little moccasins here the 215
unmarked graves that were found in
kamloops she traveled with the
delegation to cover reconciliation
meetings with pope francis with her own
piercing perspective everyone here has
been affected by residential schools one
way or another including her tina's
grandmother was forced into a
residential school her mother went to a
boarding school in my career as a
journalist now i've literally probably
interviewed hundreds of survivors
and it has affected me in a way that i
literally feel like i'm paying a piece
of my soul every time i tell a story
tina's now 15 year career got underway
with a gruesome case she intimately told
the detailed story of her missing cousin
only revealing at the end it was her
relative in a half hour special on
missing and murdered indigenous women
and girls which won an amnesty
international human rights award in 2010
all that work culminating in a watershed
moment earlier this month this is the
very first time that our voices are
being heard the metis
we have been so disenfranchised our
whole lives because of our mixed race a
proud moment for her people more than
two decades after her late father hailed
a national metis hero won this
aboriginal achievement award in 2001
and tina adding to the house family
hardware not long after her return to
canada
[Applause]
[Music]
one day to rest and boom hit the ground
and now i win national reporter for the
canadian screen awards dad if you're
here now
thank you
is this you and i love you
as the first indigenous journalist to
win that award she's making history
while also covering it
nitu garcia global news
next reading the fine print the big
donation of hundreds of very small books
[Music]
well as the saying goes don't judge a
book by its cover even if it's a teeny
tiny cover a couple of rare book
collections are catching the eye of
officials at the jewish library in
montreal
but as phil carpenter explains in order
to truly appreciate these volumes you'll
need a magnifying glass
these are probably among the smallest
books that have ever existed
oh my gosh there's a million reasons why
they're so special this is just one in a
collection of miniature books that are
about to go on display at the jewish
public library in montreal the volumes
are donated by lily toth who arranged to
have them given to the library upon her
death
there are more than a thousand i was
blown away by them i'd never seen
anything i've seen miniature books like
one here one there but to see an entire
room toth a holocaust survivor passed
away a year ago at 96. she made her way
to montreal in 1956 after the hungarian
revolution a story on dr christian
howard notes that this collection is
remarkable there are bibles and books
with bible verses that are several
hundred years old there are a lot of
more recent books which
collectors call mass market minis there
are books of poetry fine literature
children's literature cookbooks
there's even an english yiddish
dictionary from around the early 1900s
you could
put in your pockets if you're walking
around and you can't remember the
english word you can't remember the
yiddish word there's also a collection
of works of shakespeare
perhaps the smallest this
ultra-micro-miniature book of the lord's
prayer written in seven languages
measuring less than five millimeters
howard says that nowadays people buy
miniature books for artistic reasons and
collectors are rare which is why they
were surprised to learn of another
collector lily's friend daisy gross also
a holocaust survivor i love books i read
a lot
and i enjoy reading
it takes me to different world each time
you read
she owns 1300 miniature books
she doesn't know what will happen to her
collection when she passes that's not my
problem
it's up to my children gross hasn't
ruled out donating them to the library
something officials there would no doubt
be grateful for
phil carpenter global news montreal
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm sophie louie tonight
your canada is the aurora borealis
lighting up the sky over iqaluit nunavut
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna friesen will
be back at the anchor desk tomorrow have
a great night
[Music]